Hollywood studio does something showy
that actually doesn't mean anything
other breaking news water wet so I don't
know if you heard about this or not but
there is a bit of a shake-up going on
right now at Warner Brothers they are
taking the executive who had been placed
in charge of the DC EUI that's what I'm
gonna continue to call it until they
give me a different name to have it go
by and they are moving him off to
something else now he wasn't fired he
instead was given a partnering deal with
another producer who added who had a
development deal elsewhere on the lot he
got Hollywood fired which has moved off
one project and put on to another now
this on paper could theoretically mean
you know some big changes you know they
just took the the main studio guy who
was heading things up and moved him off
didn't they well yeah but it doesn't
really matter it doesn't mean anything
and we know it doesn't mean anything for
a couple of reasons the first is that
Warner Brothers has already confirmed
that this slate has not changed the
movies that haven't development are
still the movies they have in
development the movies that they have
announced at least a year that they plan
to come out they have not only said none
of these are canceled they have
reaffirmed these are the movies we are
making so nothing about the slate has
changed in any way shape or form and as
far as how important this guy's name was
dawn Berg by the way how important he
actually was is kind of a matter up for
debate he didn't even become involved in
the DCE you until Wonder Woman so he had
no part in Man of Steel Batman V
Superman or Suicide Squad he was only an
executive producer on Wonder Woman he
wasn't a full producer until justice
league and that's probably the crux of
it now he was lined up to be a producer
on a whole bunch of the stuff coming
after so he was supposed to be heading
the direction where it was going forward
but it's hard to say that he was
responsible for it at where it ended up
up to this point but he was the producer
on the ground with his hands on things
the most with Justice League and
somebody
had to take the fall for that because
Justice League is underperforming look
don't argue with me on this don't quote
me international box office no matter
what the raw number is it took this
movie almost two weeks to make as much
money as Batman V Superman made in its
opening weekend for how big a name
Justice League is and for how much money
they spent on it it is underperforming
to those expectations that is not up for
debate and really this is a move being
done to placate investors it's something
that Warner Brothers can do to make it
seem like they are taking charge and
addressing the problem when really they
they've done nothing and they took a guy
who was only just recently started to
oversee things and didn't steer the
whole thing to where it got to right now
off it and put them somewhere else and
they haven't named our placement now
that if and when a replacement does get
named that might actually make a
difference because that might give us
more of an indication as to you know who
they hire who they bring on to head this
up hey you know what there's a whole
bunch of Fox executives who might be
looking for a job soon the announcement
for the Disney Fox deal is supposed to
come out tomorrow but in addition to
that the other possibility that's
mentioned in the variety article that
broke this story is that Warner Brothers
might actually just take the DC film
division under the main Warner Brothers
Studio umbrella and handle everything
directly so to kind of explain up to
this point DC and the DC movies have
been following the Marvel production
model and again I'm talking about the
manner in which production was handled
odd not I understand they were handling
things differently don't give me that
Jeezy doesn't different from a
production standpoint they adopted
marvel's model which was that the studio
that was dedicated to nothing but the
superhero films was basically autonomous
within the company it had its own heads
and its own resources that it was
working with that's the same way Disney
runs Marvel when does the acquired
Marvel Marvel had its studio up and
running and Disney said you know what
you're good I mean you answered us now
but you're good
do your thing well
we'll step in if we have to and they
haven't had to and Marvel continues to
operate pretty much independent of
Disney and that was how the DC films
were working now Warner Brothers sort of
if they absorb that and bring it under
the main Warner Brothers banner and then
it's all being done by the studio that
is under more direct control of the head
executives of the studio that would be
adopting the Foxx approach to how Fox
made the x-men movies because they did
not have a dedicated internal or a third
party sort of farmed out studio working
on the x-men movies they were being done
directly in-house at Fox and this is not
a huge surprise but kind of interesting
all the same because it basically what
it feels like it feels like Warner
Brothers is going okay we were using
this one business model and that didn't
work let's try the other one cuz really
up to this point if you're talking about
continually produced and maintained
superhero franchises there's really only
two to go on that you would want to
emulate because you know when I know
like spider-man they're on their third
reboot so I mean there's Fox who did
everything in house and there's Marvel
and Disney who had a dedicated smaller
studio and Warner Brothers tried one
didn't work now they're gonna try the
other and if they opt to do that rather
than just bring in a new head to be the
executive of DC as an independence as a
more or less independent thing that
that's not a good sign as far as I'm
concerned because that move presumes
that you know the studio was some kind
of Wild West scenario and it needed more
executive oversight except that if you
look at a lot of what's gone on with a
lot of these films it feels like
executive mandate was a big part of a
problem now let's for the moment let's
set B V s and even Man of Steel and
Snyder let's set his stuff aside for the
moment because this is not just about
whether or not the Snyder Vision worked
okay because you look at something like
Suicide Squad there was sick
weeks to write it David Ayer was
basically given a list of characters
said right as a script make the movie
and then when he started presenting the
movie they had a trailer cut together
that was a completely different tone
from the movie decided that the trailer
was gonna do better brought in other
people to recut the movie to be more
like the trailer this is all executive B
s moves this this is because of
executive oversight giving more
executive oversight by bring it directly
under the control of Warner Brothers I
don't see how that helps the problem it
wasn't that they needed more executive
oversight they needed better executive
oversight they need it they need a Kevin
Feige it's what they need and you know
when I sight Kevin Feige I'm not just
saying they need saw and they need
someone to literally replicate Marvel's
model in terms of tone and everything
else I mean they need somebody who not
only cares knows how to manage a movie
studio but cares about these properties
because so far as I can tell most of the
executives they put on these things
they're just this is just the job
they've gotten aside to I don't know a
lot about John Berg but he's a
relatively young guy and as far as
executives go and he hasn't been doing
this for all that long he's actually
gone more credits on his eyen IMDB
listing for announced projects he's
supposed to be producing then once he's
actually completed up to this point he
is a young up-and-coming guy who is
getting thrown under the bus to make it
look like they're doing something and
like I said to placate investors because
they really need to do that at this
point you're probably not aware of this
but what a brother stock took a big hit
in the last couple months basically in
the immediate lead-up to Justice League
and then following it it dropped and
when I say dropped I mean it lost a
year's worth of growth its back down to
where it was this time last year and it
had been growing in the interim now is
that all down to Justice League no
probably not there's probably other
factors involved with that but you have
to imagine Justice League
underperforming has to be a big factor
because Justice League underperforming
is about more than just Justice League
because that puts into question
everything that is D
related this supposed to come out after
and I don't mean puts into question like
will they make it yes they'll still make
it they want to make money off this and
in their mind if they have these
properties and they're not producing
something then they're leaving money on
the table but it does bring into
question how what kind of return they
can expect to see from that and that
makes investors nervous and when
investors get nervous Studios get
panicky and do weird showy stupid stuff
so what I even feel the need to talk
about of this I suppose it's because I
don't want anybody I I don't I don't
enjoy taking hope away from people I
know I'm a grumpy cynical bastard I
accept that but I get very sad when I
see people clinging to hope that doesn't
have anything behind it it literally is
just hope and there's no foundation and
look if you like the DC movies or if you
are crossing your fingers for them to
get better or whatever your stake in
them is you can't look at this move and
go oh this means everything's got to get
better now I know it doesn't they did it
they did a minor reshuffle for show and
they're not changing the slate and
they're not changing any of the
directors or anything else
so look Warner Brothers you want a
recommendation cuz I know you don't
listen why would you but I'll give you
one anyway for free you can have it you
need to stop trotting out Jeff Jones
just to placate fans because that's what
you've been doing you keep talking up
what Jeff Jones yellow and we have this
great celebrated beloved comic writer
who helping us well here's the thing
you have got him helping on so many
things the TV the movies he's still
working with on the comics end of things
that his level of input it basically it
cannot possibly be more than he glances
at some sketches or at an early script
gives a couple of notes and then goes on
to somewhere else he is not dedicated to
working on these things exclusively
again to make the comparison of Kevin
Feige Kevin Feige manages the movies he
doesn't manage the movies and the TV and
the Netflix and the comic
he manages one thing and he does it very
well now good Jeff John's actually
managed the movies by himself if you
gave him more direct control I have no
idea I'm not gonna make that claim
because he is a good comic book writer
but being a good comic book writer
doesn't make you a good head of a small
studio so I have absolutely no idea but
you do need to either decide are you
going to trust this guy and actually
give him some power and some ability to
affect change indirect to the actual
thing or are you just going to
occasionally check in with him to
placate fans and make it think you to
make it seem like you're listening to us
from really you not while you have
another corporate guy actually pulling
the strings
because if that's what you're gonna
continue to do just stop eating up his
time with the movies at all then let him
get back to writing comics is what we
know he's actually good at again he may
be good at the stuff but at the movie
stuff but you aren't giving him the
authority to find out if that's true or
not either give him the authority so
that we can find out if he's actually
well suited to this and then if he is or
isn't go from there or just just get him
off that let him do what he's good at
what we know he's good at stop beating
up his time and stop insulting us by
trotting him out to promote these things
and acting like we're listening to the
fans cuz no you're not you're listening
to the fact that people aren't going to
your movies as much but trying out Geoff
Johns doesn't fix that so there you go
Warner Brothers that one's free that's
on me
you want any more advice I'm gonna
charge you okay I think I'm letting the
fact that that occasionally I get
comments like oh you should be hired as
a consult by sony or words or whatever I
think I'm letting those get to my head I
say those as if they happen a lot I
think they have like once per video it's
probably the same person saying it every
time I appreciate it all the same you
know what I gotta wrap this up I'm
rambling at this point so thanks so much
for joining and what are your thoughts
on the shake-up at Warner Brothers I am
so tired of talking industry and
corporate BS tomorrow I'm gonna go see
Star Wars that's what I'm gonna
so whatever your thoughts on this mess
were drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council G's council geeks podcast is on
Apple podcast and stitcher radio I'm
also might half of the punch like a girl
bought gas that is a presentation of the
fire motto podcast network Fire Water
podcast calm leaks for everything is
down below and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]